we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about we've
got the CrossFit white-eyed surf set
cardio mission in boot camp it's your
body
I'm like I created serfs a serf set has
a brand-new workout it's serf inspired
yeah we have a piece of equipment called
the RIP sir 4x that mimics a surfboard
on water and what we're going for is big
core focusing on a full body workout
high-intensity interval training surf
set really started out of necessity I
couldn't get to the ocean I really loved
the way that the of body type and a
fitness level that I attained while
surfing so I needed to create a workout
that could mimic that so as a so as a
professional hockey player to this day
I'm still blown away that I could cross
train surfing and be ready to play
hockey surf set workout is full-body so
we're gonna be working your chest
triceps your core is always gonna be
engaged just from you're trying to get
up on the board quads hamstrings glutes
there's really not a muscle that you're
not gonna be working but I think that's
the really interesting part about surf
set
it's not about fitness as much as it is
about athleticism
here's the surf set three minute workout
here's your three-minute at-home surf
set working we're gonna replicate the
board by actually putting a piece of
tape down and just making sure that
you're in line and balanced and Eric
here is gonna be my guinea pig so we're
gonna get started there you go all right
so first thing we're gonna come down in
a prone position right in a push-up so I
want you to split the line if you can
it's just about like this yep so I'm
gonna come down flat onto your stomach
all right now we're gonna bring our
hands out to the side just hang it up
yep now you'll bring your feet up okay
from here this is gonna be the first
move in the pop up what I want you to do
is bring your feet and hands down
simultaneously okay and then explode up
to that push-up plank so big thing to
remember here tight core make sure
you're nice and controlled on the way
down all right hit it when you're ready
all right
don't wait all right hopped up too much
too much that's all right missed that
way if so this time we're just gonna
come up to that push-up plank flat back
tight core got chuddy all right let's go
there's one make sure it goes fast you
can
explosions drawn that poor tight so
second movement we're gonna do is move
those feet to your hands to simulate
that pop up we're under a little bit
more control it's the same thing we're
gonna explode up drive those feet
forward right up to a squat are just
going to have to standing right down to
squats back down to that prone position
so I'll wait for the burpees
slide forward right up two squats right
back down drop it back nice up
pick up the pace we're gonna try and
beat you now you're saying what does
this have to do with surfing so the next
step of this is we're gonna add 1/4
occasion so you're gonna actually turn
your feet to the side both sides you
want to make sure we're symmetrical
right we want to walk around in a circle
so we're gonna train both sides of the
body so I want you to do is same thing
down prone hands up feet up and this
time it's one step so we're gonna
demonstrate first okay so we're gonna do
we're gonna come down as we explode up
that foots coming forward all right and
we're gonna turn to the side nice
control back down and we're gonna go to
each side yep
that's alright
this time we're gonna pick up the speed
and we're going to throw that coal
rotation in the air so we're gonna be
popping up almost pushing herself off
the ground and make a new room for those
feet to slide forward and fix the trends
the right and left gonna do both sides
nice and nice and controlled landing
right in the middle that stringer writes
down feet up hands up
push it nice and control back down you
got all right go right into it
nice right back down up right back down
all right actually the thing that's
tough pretty look how we do it 177 on
the heart rate all right it's not that
hard to breathe I'm good hey thank you
very much thank you
all right so to recap that was 10 prone
to planks with your five burpees then we
did two full rotations both sides and to
full pop ups you're gonna repeat that
workout twice and that's your full three
minute mini working make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
other fighting weight episodes